[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au no2 petit ami
nicolas et pimprenelle ont-ils été sage
aujourd'hui
howie patron oui d'accord mon cher
nounours pour les récompenser tu va leur
montrer ton beau livre d'image qui nous
allons leur raconter une belle histoire
je cours pas trop alors que je suis nue
go j'oubliais de prendre bon tu ne
changeras jamais mon gros nounours ce
vrai patron bon le seul homme peut pas
concevoir les hauts-fonds ce mois
nounours ah non qu'est ce que tu nous
est apportée que tu vois bien que c'est
un livre d'image comme les enfants
bykhal là je vois là
comme vous avez été très sage je vais
vous montrer un bon livre d'image et
notre ami le marchand de sable va vous
en raconter l'histoire ce cas là c'est
une très jolie histoire que m'a raconté
ma moment il y à très très long cigare
silence nikaïa a dit écoutez bien car
est très amusant c'est l'histoire de la
petite améthyste à vous autres ont il y
avait une fois il y à bien en temps une
petite fille qui s'appelait améthyste
pourquoi mais qui elle en avait un
branle de nom parce qu'elle avait de
grands yeux tout bleu de la couleur
d'une jolie pierre précieuse qu'on
appelle améthyste elle vivait dans la
forêt avec ses parents et avec les amis
de ses parents
les animaux est ce qu'elle est mignonne
elle en a deux rôles de vêtements didot
écoute laussucq plus offrant il habitait
dans une petite maison en paille et se
lever très tôt le matin avec le soleil
le papa d'améthyste qui était bûcheron
partait travailler dans la forêt sa
maman allait faire les commissions et
notre petit améthyste rester tout seul
dans la grande forêt qu'est ce qu'il
faisait tout y est elle fait s'ennuyer
elle n'avait pas peur non elle jouait
avec tous ses amis de jolis oiseaux de
toutes les couleurs et elle joué aussi à
cache cache avec les biches et des
chevreuils parce qu'ils sont mignons dit
nous nous tous les animaux de la forêt
était gentil avec elle
sauf un méchant serpent
un gros vilain tigre et cet énorme
crocodile qui aurait bien voulu la
manger il est bête
ce sont là les parents d'améthyste lui
avait bien recommandé de faire attention
et d'être très prudente
mais un jour qu'elle était parti trop
loin dans la forêt elle rencontra le
gros crocodile la la gueule grande
ouverte et voulait la manger au lot
oui il voulait la manger quand tout à
coup un gros bras couverts de poils
l'enleva en l'air c'était toi dino nord
ce que tu connais
non ce ne te pas voir le zoo c'était son
ami le singe qu'il avait ainsi sauvé et
il la posa sur la branche d'un arbre qui
bougeait et se balancer et améthyste
trouvé ça très amusant mais ses parents
qui étaient rentrés à la maison était
fort inquiet et l'a cherché partout mais
il retrouve évidemment il l'entend dire
qu'ils riaient qui riaient et en levant
la tête il la vire dans l'arbre en train
de se balancer avec le gros seins
et ils furent très heureux de la
retrouver mais aussi de voir qu'elle
avait inventé un jeu nouveau très
amusant qu'on appelle maintenant la
balançoire qu'il était jolie cette
histoire
merci petit marchand de sable allons lui
petit ou doudou
[Musique]
onu une petite zone là justin a lieu à
thonon
ninon à demain nicolas je n'eus pas
preneur
alors les enfants l'histoire vous a plu
oui tant mieux si vous êtes bien sage
on vous en racontera d'autres et
maintenant allez vite vous coucher
allons en route mon cher nounours bonne
nuit les enfants fais de beaux rêves
à demain fête de brouwer à 2
[Musique]